black holes are mysterious anomalies in
space whose nature we're only just
starting to understand
they are hard to detect and even harder
to explore
space itself around these captivating
objects changes beyond recognition
and the physical laws we're used to do
not apply there by studying black holes
we find out more about the deeper
meaning of our universe
however at the same time it also poses a
certain threat
so how dangerous are black holes
[Music]
first
it goes without saying that to detect a
celestial object that absorbs all light
shed on it is a challenging task to say
the least that is why there are not that
many confirmed black hole candidates
today
still mathematical modelling shows that
their number in our galaxy may reach 100
million
this may seem an incredibly big number
but since there are 200 to 400 billion
stars in the milky way it makes us
realize that in all these expanses black
holes or objects one doesn't come across
that much
in one of our previous videos on the
topic we mentioned that a star the
progenitor of a black hole has to have a
mass of at least 18 to 20 solar masses
only this will ensure a powerful enough
supernova to compress the scorching hot
core of the star to an exceptionally
dense clump of material
after this has occurred nothing will be
able to stand up to the object's gravity
force and escape beyond the boundaries
of a conventional sphere predefined by
the so-called schwarzschild radius
what used to be a star transforms into a
bizarre object with an inner makeup that
would defy description by the physical
laws we're familiar with
the object referred to as a0620-00
or v616 is one of the black holes
closest to our earth that we know of
it lies 3
300 light years away from our planet and
forms part of a binary star in the
constellation monoseries
the other object in the system is an
orange dwarf with a mass half that of
the sun
every 7.75
hours it completes a full orbit around
an invisible object of unknown nature
estimates show the mass of this
invisible object to be around 6.6 times
that of the sun
it is admittedly too much for a neutron
star
this leads one to believe that the
bizarre invisible object is more likely
than not a black hole
in addition to getting deformed and
elongated by the more massive neighbor's
gravity the orange dwarf is also getting
stripped of the outer layers of stella
mata
spiraling streams of scorching gas
gradually flow to the black hole and
form a bright accretion disk
it is thanks to this dazzling disk that
the black hole was detected
there are at least several dozen stars
in the environs of v616
some of which almost certainly have
their own planetary systems
it is highly likely that in the future
one of these stars will get dangerously
close to the black hole and as a result
will be sucked in by the object's insane
gravity
this unfortunate star will have no
choice and in this case the same slow
demise is eventually awaiting the black
hole's new companion as that of its
current one
the process of interaction of a black
hole with other objects largely depends
on their mass ratio
the smaller the distance between them
and the more massive the black hole the
stronger the influence of its tidal
forces over its companion
the star may be deformed by them and
gets stretched towards the system's
common mass center
they can also form channels that would
carry stellar matter closer to the black
hole adding up to its accretion disk
if the tidal forces happen to be strong
enough they may well destroy the object
that is being sucked in by turning it
into a fiery ring
it is assumed that there may be planets
orbiting a black hole just as if it were
a regular star
in contrast to a widespread opinion
black holes are actually not able to
suck in all objects around them
indiscriminately
from the point of view of gravitation in
astronomical terms they behave just like
any star with the same mass
that is why incredibly though it may
seem a black hole may well have a stable
planetary system
there are several ways for them to form
firstly new celestial objects may
originate in a nebula of gas and dust
that is formed after a supernova
influenced by gravitation they're first
form clumps of material that collide
with each other and attract cosmic dust
as a result they eventually turn into
planets and satellites as well as large
numbers of small celestial objects like
asteroids and comets
the radiation of the black holes
accretion disk may be powerful enough to
warm them and even melt ice on their
surfaces
hypothetically a planetary system like
that could be favorable enough for life
to originate and with any luck evolve
secondly when a black hole captures and
destroys another planetary system some
of its objects may choose to take up
stable orbital positions around their
new host
of course this makeover would bring
about dramatic changes on the celestial
object's surfaces
thus a nice giant may transform into an
ocean planet and a gas giant may lose
almost all of its hydrogen and turn into
a thonian planet
thirdly
space wanderers like rogue planets or
interstellar asteroids may also be
ensnared by the massive object's gravity
even though systems like that have not
yet been discovered in practice there is
no reason to suppose they are
non-existent
if on the other hand a planet is too
close to the system's center and the
black hole is massive enough other
factors come into play
a scorching hot stream of material
forming the accretion disk will strip
the celestial object of its atmosphere
and its friction will slow it down and
pull it still closer to the black hole
eventually extremely powerful tidal
forces will rip the planet to tiny
shreds
the debris will be pulled into the
accretion disk
and gradually melt in the hot gas around
in the end they will inevitably get
swallowed up by the black hole and in
essence become part of it
it is posited that there are three main
types of black holes to be found in the
universe at are different first and
foremost in terms of their mass
the first type can be found in the
center of most spiral galaxies
these are gargantuan black holes with
masses reaching several billion solar
masses the density of matter in the
central part of a galaxy is generally
extremely high
which is the reason why they originate a
big number of large and bright stars
quite closely packed as they rapidly
burn out they transform into black holes
which in their turn rapidly grow and
often merge with each other
as a result supermassive objects are
born which are surrounded with giant
accretion disks made of scorching hot
material they illume in space so
brightly that it makes them seen from
billions of light years away even if
their galaxy is completely unobservable
to us
these objects are known as quasars
the second type is much more widespread
but at the same time black holes like
these are not that easily detectable
their masses are close to those of stars
and they form out of large stars at the
end of the latter's life cycle
by devouring other celestial bodies and
interstellar gas
these objects gradually gain in size and
eventually turn into intermediate mass
black holes
they can also merge together which
generates gravity waves that distort
space many light years around
the third type is the hypothetical
primary black holes
their existence has been inferred from
today's theory of universe's origins and
evolution
fluctuations and matter that filled
space in its early stages of evolution
may have been favorable for black holes
of infinitely small size to originate
it should be mentioned that according to
estimates the smaller an object of this
type the faster it evaporates and at the
end of its life cycle it turns into a
tremendously powerful electromagnetic
impulse
modeling shows that primary black holes
with masses around 10 to the power of 12
kilograms are supposed to be flaring up
sometime around now
but to date no such event has been
registered yet
according to a certain hypothesis a
microscopic black hole may form on
collision of extra high energy
elementary particles
this variety is referred to as quantum
black holes
still the conditions necessary for such
an event to happen are impossible to be
reproduced in lab conditions and
estimated life expectancy of these
hypothetical objects is so small that it
can hardly be measured with today's
latest and most advanced methods
that is why quantum black holes still
officially exist only in theory
of course it is extremely difficult to
detect such dark and compact objects
some of them happen to have a star
companion whose anomalous trajectory of
movement gives telltale prompts of there
being an invisible thing in close
proximity
another popular method of detection is
observation of accretion disks
these objects spectra have some typical
features that allow telling them from
other sources of light in space
sometimes we're lucky enough to get a
snapshot of a disk with a black spot in
it that is evidence that the observed
object's structure is quite unusual
a black hole may also be detected thanks
to the gravitational microlensing effect
this involves detecting the massive
invisible object as it transits between
the earth and a remote star
this changes the star's spectrum in a
special way
but admittedly
this method requires a number of rare
factors to successfully work
there is hardly any doubt that space is
filled with great numbers of objects
that are dark and not easily noticeable
there may be wandering black holes among
them
these mysterious objects roaming around
in interstellar space and absorbing
every bit of light they come across
will probably never reveal their secrets
to us
you